Hey youtubers it's Charlie and the fist full
trailer for Series 8 just posted. So this
is going to be a full breakdown into darkness.
The funny thing is, when they posted it I
was finishing a Series 8 Dalek bonus video.
So I'll try to post that in a couple hours
too. Double Doctor Who today.
Hello any new people, if you're finding me
for the first time I do Doctor Who every week.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything. I've
got a lot of special stuff planned for when
the episodes start airing.
Trailer time. I know there have been a lot
of leaks lately too, if you're one of the
people who has read the scripts or seen the
black and white episode please use spoiler
tags if you're going to comment on them.
I haven't seen the leaks, but I will include
rumors because some of the images support
them.
This is just going to be a shot for shot breakdown
of the trailer. It's a full minute of footage,
all the previous teasers have been really
short.
Starting off with the TARDIS controls moving
through a montage of a new shot of a corridor.
It could be inside the TARDIS but I've never
seen any passageways in the TARDIS that look
like this. There are rumors that Clara and
the Doctor will be traveling inside a Dalek
in Series 8, so this corridor could be the
interior of a Dalek.
Supported by the appearances of Clara looking
like she's in a waking dream that moves to
a close up of a Dalek eye stalk. It also kind
of makes me think of Dalek Oswin from the
Series 7 Opener.
I love the sound effects during that, the
way the images pulse with the music and the
Dalek voice over makes it sound like a heartbeat.
This Clara is the Clara from the Christmas
special though. She's got a new haircut in
the series 8 promo pics, so we're not looking
at a different version of her.
The voiceover "Life Returns" is both a play
on Dalek life and The Doctor's new life a
la Capaldi.
It's super noir-ish and I know a lot of people
are drawing parallels to the Fourth Doctor's
run.
As we see the interior of the TARDIS not exploding
and it looks exactly like Matt Smith's new
TARDIS from the 2012 christmas special the
Snowmen. This confirms that Peter Capaldi
will for all intents and purposes have the
same TARDIS.
I know everyone has been asking about his
sonic, but here we can see him holding Smith's
sonic too. So it seems like he won't get a
new one anytime soon. Maybe in Series 9.
I love how through all of this the Dalek Voiceover
talks about Life Prevailing, like we're all
buzzing because of the Doctor's triumph in
the christmas special and his new set of regenerations
but underneath it all the Dalek is probably
talking about Dalek Life prevailing.
The Time Lords and the Daleks are the two
most enduring races in the galaxy, so it only
makes sense that for every victory of the
Doctor's, the Daleks also achieve victory.
Here's the first beautiful full on shot of
Capaldi from actual footage. And he's wearing
a tie, which is a nice callback to Tennant.
This seems like a temporary costume, since
he's been revealed to not have any neckwear
with his official main series 8 costume.
There have been a lot of set pics from the
first episode in victorian london, so this
is probably from episode 1. I love the look.
And the hard stare. Everyone seems to think
of Capaldi defining trait as the Doctor so
far is his eyes. And right now I agree.
This is also the first time we've heard Capaldi
acknowledge himself as The Doctor.
The mechanical man we see also looks like
he's from that victorian episode. There were
rumors a long time ago that the Clockwork
robots from Girl in the Fireplace were making
a comeback and I think this answers that.
Yes robots, no to Clockwork robots.
Although this bird looking robot reminds me
of the clockwork owl from Clash of the Titans,
bubo. Like a terminator version of Bubo. That
can't be good.
Capaldi states that he's over two thousand
years, which is interesting because it was
kind of hard to pinpoint his age after spending
so long on Trenzalore in the christmas special.
The best estimate right now is that he's 2100
years old.
Here's one of the new aliens and it looks
like it's wearing one of the Doctor's spacesuits.
So it might be friendly. If the doctor gave
it a spacesuit. No idea which episode it appears
in, but it looks like they're in a bank vault
and the new Ms Delphox villain character works
at a bank in the future. So they might appear
in the same episode.
The montage of explosions don't necessarily
have to be from the same episode, but it's
possible that they're all from that future
Ms Delphox episode. The bank story is rumored
to be a heist. It takes place in the far future
and those containers look fairly futuristic.
So it could all be from that.
This looks like a nighttime shot of Victorian
London from that rumored first episode.
When the Doctor is talking to Clara about
fixing his mistakes he looks like he's wearing
his new costume. You can't see the red lining,
but it's very reminiscent of the third doctor's
cape.
Clara is also wearing a new leather jacket,
so presumably this scene is after he comes
to his senses. After the TARDIS stops crashing
like at the end of the christmas special.
He says they're going into Darkness, and I
think that could mean two things, it could
literally mean into the void between universes.
It's just like a black nothingness. Supposedly
all the Daleks and Cybermen and things living
in the void died as a result of the reality
bomb in doomsday.
It could also be a reference to that rumored
Dalek story, them going inside the darkness
of a Dalek. Like the Magical School bus from
hell.
Then we seen Madam Vastra, pretty much confirming
a paternoster Victorian Episode.
Clara is falling down a shaft that could be
anywhere, TARDIS, Dalek or somewhere in the
future.
T-REX In London. Fairly self explanatory.
If you look at the background smoke stack.
It suggests that this is also from Victorian
London and that Vastra episode. Can't wait
for the explanation of this.
Mega Dalek Fleet, which confirms Daleks but
without a lot of context we can't really be
sure what they're doing in series 8. As of
the Christmas Special they were really just
trying to prevent the Doctor from bringing
back the Time Lords.
This is one of the Robots from Mark Gatiss'
episode, Robots of Sherwood. Tom Riley plays
Robin Hood and I can't wait to see it. It's
like a full on renfair episode of Doctor Who.
Capaldi on Horseback, also in Victorian London.
This looks like the Doctor inside another
room of the TARDIS, or in the far future.
Daleks again, cut in a montage with what looks
like the TARDIS traveling inside the Medusa
Cascade or the void between universes. Right
now I'm thinking Medusa Cascade is more likely
due to the Davros Speech in the last trailer.
Then we see the Doctor asking Clara if he's
a good man. They used this in the last trailer
but it seems much less sinister in this scene.
So he's probably just asking her geniunily
because he's still making sense of his mind
after the regeneration.
When she says she doesn't know I'm wondering
if she's saying it because of his new personality
or if she's realizing that she didn't ever
really know the Doctor, not as well as she
thought she did.
And that's it, I'm thinking based on the footage
they used. All of these trailer scenes are
from the first couple of episodes. Again,
if you're read the leaked scripts, please
use spoiler tags if you're going
to comment.
Like I said, I have a Dalek video I'm going
to finish and post in a few hours. Be sure
to subscribe to get it. We're almost a couple
weeks away from the premiere. Doctor Who will
be going on the Press Tour, so if it's coming
to a city near you, definitely try to go.
It's already sold out, so if you have a ticket.
Be sure to post pictures. Feel free to post
them on my facebook page. There's a link to
that at the bottom of the description.
I'm expecting another trailer before the premiere,
so we will get to see some more new footage
soon.
Right now click here for that Dalek Video
and click here to learn all about Sherlock
Series 4.
Thanks for watching, see you guys in a little
bit. High Fives!